very few people in today's world need to
be persuaded that faiths hair can have
divisive indeed a destructive impact in
the world today in many cases fates have
contributed to increasing violence in
the world true most of these cases of
conflicts are not strictly religious
conflicts waged around a particular
religious issue religions faiths are
contributing factors among many other
factors because most of these conflicts
are not caused by one thing but by many
things economic issues political issues
cultural issues and so on in this
discussions we're interested in
exploring is faith an inherently violent
force or are there particular conditions
which make faith become violent we're
also interested in exploring what might
be possible resources of faith in order
to counter the tendency for them to be
misused for violent purposes in order to
get clarity about these issues we would
like to explore the role of Orthodox
faith Orthodox Christian faith in the
conflicts in former Yugoslavia and also
role of Buddhism in conflicts in Sri
Lanka